I'm now joined by a conservative MP it's
Andrew bridgen writer of letters to get
rid of Tory prime ministers
was it the right decision what should
happen next
yes it was the right decision
um clearly Liz trust had lost the
confidence not only of the Parliamentary
party but the public at large I think
when you get to minus 70 on personal
approvals
um you're basically giving Vladimir
Putin a push a run for his money aren't
you there was no way back so she's done
The Honorable thing the right thing to
do
a very quick leadership election I hope
that all the main contenders can come
together in the National interest some
egos will have to be put to one side I
want to see a government of conservative
of all the talents we've got on the back
benches which are considerable all wings
of the party
and I think
the state of politics we find ourselves
in today
if the party can't do that and we can't
coalesce around a leadership a new prime
minister and a leadership team and we're
heading for a general election you say
that's the last thing that that we want
and probably the country wants when
we're facing so many challenges you say
all the big beasts should stand can you
just name them for us so I've been
speculating itself but who who are you
talking about well all the people who
stood in the summer I think they've got
to have a place at the table I think
it's probably between Rishi and Penny
who's the most acceptable but I hope
that we won't have to even run the full
week I I'm hoping that they can all get
together and and come up with it with a
team that will be acceptable
um as I say some egos will have to be uh
sacrificed in the National interest and
in the interest of the conservative
party so if it does boil down to a big
big difficult choice between Richie
sumac and penny more than well what is
that choice is it a choice between
economic competence but not necessarily
flare at the dispatch box and on behalf
of Rishi ability to absolutely command
the House of Commons chamber dispatch
opponents but a slightly uncertain uh
economic stance from penny board is that
is that a fair way of describing the
choice if it does boil down to those two
I think it's a bit more nuanced than
that I think they're both very capable
politicians and I would add that I think
um Jeremy Hunt's probably secured his
place as Chancellor I think it would be
irresponsible for anyone in the short
term to to move him from that position
uh at the moment so I think we've got
all wings of the party potentially can
be in that cabinet and I I think that's
the best way forward let's say if if
those egos can't be uh sacrificed a
little bit in the National interest what
we'll focus the minds is we would have
to go for a general election
um if we can't form a stable government
the one person who might not be willing
to stand behind a Unity ticket that
might disrupt some of this it's been
suggested to me is Zoella Braverman do
you think that's possible what's your
message to her now Sue Ella uh
represents my wing of the party if you
like
um I think the problem with the right
wing of the party I was probably only
one of five or six of us who didn't
didn't backliz
um and I think there's you know
the right wing of the party my wing of
the party has taken a bit of a a bit of
a dent we'll need Sue Ella uh in the
cabinet for sure because uh she's she's
our flag bearer she's a fellow Spartan
with me but but she has been playing
footsie with the Tory members do you
know she's not going to disrupt this
attempt that was prior to listro's uh
announcement this afternoon we're in a
different territory now
let's be sure the conservative party
where the polling is today we are
drinking in The Last Chance Saloon uh
and everyone has to recognize that and
if they don't well they deserve what
will be coming to us
um forgive me you Andrew bridge and
serial writer of letters to get rid of
prime minister and now telling Sky
viewers that the most important thing is
unity in the conservative party after
everything that we've seen I mean isn't
it isn't it hard to it's a bit hard to
take that uh that's just four letters in
nearly 13 years I mean uh there was four
letters in about five years yeah over
the last and at the end of the day when
I you know when I when I announced I was
putting my letter in the prime ministers
always went I certainly wasn't the only
person in the Parliamentary party who it
was of that view and I think they were
the right decisions at the right time
and that's what I'm telling you now we
need down to coalesce around a new prime
minister but also a team and they've got
to represent all wings of the party this
isn't just about personality and prime
minister it's about policy C2 just very
briefly Jeremy Hunt has to decide the
most difficult Cuts in a generation on
behalf of the conservative party without
knowing who the prime minister is who at
the very last minute is going to have to
sign off on them that's politically
unsustainable isn't it
um
I'm sure that we're all going to have
input on to what Jeremy Hunt's going to
have to do in in his budget
the answer is also to to get rid of hs2
and cut your losses now which is a huge
amount of money but that's another one
of my little hobby horses right now it
sounds like Jeremy Hunt though is the
most powerful person
in government
he arrived at a time of Crisis he's done
a competent job he's reassured the
markets he's secured his place at the
table he's already announced he wouldn't
stand in the leadership he's got his
work to do
I hope other potential cabinet members
will take such a responsible attitude to
the roles they're going to have to do
for the party and the country over the
next week or two final question
um do you lean currently towards any of
the big beasts are you a bit more of a
Rishi sunak fan now are you a bit more
of a penny more than tight are you are
you even Stevens are you up for grabs
I'm comfortable with either of them I
think they're both very competent
politicians but I think it will be one
of those two and will it be a vote that
determines that amongst MPS
if they were to come to me tomorrow and
say we've decided between ourselves we
don't need a vote this is what we've got
uh and he's a I would accept that either
way
um or if we have to have one round of
voting to see who's in front what I
don't really want is that someone's got
49 and someone's got 51 and the
divisions continue because we can't have
that continue we must move forward now
as a team we've got two years to the
next general election and uh if we move
forward competently what's happened over
the last few few weeks or will be seen
as an aberration rather than the norm it
can't be the norm thank you very much
indeed Andrew bridgen